اسبوع خامس من الاقتتال العسكري يشهده
السودان فلا جديد سوى اصوات الانفجارات
والقصف والمعارك بين كل من الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع نبدا ميدانيه مشاهدينا حيث
افادت مصادر العربيه بتجدد الاشتباكات
وسماع صوت الانفجارات في العاصمه الخرطوم
حيث استخدم الجيش الطائرات الحربيه لقصف
مواقع الدعم السريع فيما اعلنت طبعا الامم
المتحده هنا ارتفاع عدد القتلى قتل
الاشتباكات الى حوالي 680 قتيلا كما
تواصلت الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله نتحدث
هنا بمدينه الجنينه غربي دارفور بعدما
تصدت قوات الجيش لهجوم من الدعم السريع في
ثلاث اتجاهات على الجنينه اما على صعيد
المبادرات والمباحثات الجاريه في جده التي
تستانف اليوم فيها الجوله الثانيه التي
تتركز حول كيفيه تنفيذ خطط ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه
طبعا القوات من المناطق الميدانيه وفق ما
ذكرت هنا رويترز عن مصدر دبلوماسي سعودي
ومع تجدد الاشتباكات مددت سلطه الطيران
المدني في السودان اغلاق المجال الجوي
امام حركه الطيران حتى نهايه الشهر الجاري
بدوره هنا حذر حزب
المؤتمر السوداني من انزلاق البلاد الى
حرب اهليه شامله مع غياب اجهزه الدوله
وداعا الى التنفيذ الفوري لاعلان جده الذي
وقعه ممثلو الجيش ودعم السريع مؤخرا
تستسلم من ذلك مشاهدينا رحلات المساعدات
الانسانيه كما اصبح معلوم ورحلات الاجلاء
بعد الحصول على تصريح من قبل الجهات
المختصه والمسؤوله هي عن تلك العمليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيه ات